news the day before christmas and
millions of americans you may be one of
them still waiting to see if your gifts
are going to get to where they need to
go on time
even though the major mail carriers say
most packages are getting where they
need to go
more than a million orders may fall
short errol burnett has that story
in a year unlike any other the race for
shippers to deliver packages to homes
and businesses nationwide
is reaching its pinnacle everybody
understands that their people been doing
a lot more
online shopping that the delivery system
is flooded with packages
the us postal service is getting hit
hard shipping millions more items a day
than
average partially due to shipping caps
at ups and fedex
in the first week of december first
class on time deliveries
fell to just 75 percent what is it like
to be a postal worker right now well
it's
it's daunting mark diminsteen is the
president of the american postal workers
union
in addition to deliveries he says more
than 6
000 workers have tested positive for
covid in just the last
week with all of that we're still out
here
like all other essential workers should
people brace themselves and expect
that things may be a little late this
week i i think in some
situations people
will be disappointed private carriers
are also overwhelmed
last week ups health care president wes
wheeler warned our chris van cleave
of potential holiday gift delays as the
covet 19 vaccine
rolled out across the country if it
comes down to it what gets priority
my christmas gifts or the vaccine the
vaccines will get
they'll get the first priority on the
aircraft first priority on the package
car when it goes to the final
destination
now despite all of these delays there
are still some companies willing to
offer you a
last minute chance of getting your
packages where they need to be on time
for a price
amazon target and walmart are offering
same day delivery on thursday for
millions of items
errol barnett cbs news new york